I think I've unfairly strong ground when
I say that we haven't yet in computer
file done recursion this can get
extremely hard it is difficult to get
your head around recursion sometimes in
one way you can take a very mathematical
view about it just close your eyes and
if you're a pure mathematician who
thinks as we computer scientists would
say exclusively top-down and how things
can say oh it's just a formal definition
you know here's an example of something
you can do recursively factorial of n is
equal to n times factorial of n minus 1
and if you're used to mathematical
thinking well that's absolutely all
right of course
they will then go on thank heavens and
say our but you've got to stop that
you're just going round and round
chasing your own tail
because what about factorial n minus 1
men well factorial n minus 1 is the same
as n minus 1 times factorial n minus 2
and the mathematician would say oh yes
all you're doing is relabeling the ends
you know what was n now becomes n minus
1 and so on and yes that's quite right
but at the bottom of all of this you
could have a way of dropping out and
terminating this endless succession of
things defined in terms of themselves
you're way out of all this is that when
you hit factorial 1 that is defined to
be 1 so let's take an actual real
example of this and one which we will
later develop with a program what we're
saying I'll abbreviate it now as fact
rather than factorial factorial for from
this definition is 4 times whatever
factorial of 4 minus 1 3 is but
factorial 3 is 3 times whatever
factorial 2 is factorial 2 is 2 times
whatever factorial 1 is our
factorial one is one so there we are
then
factorial 4 is 4 times 3 times 2 times 1
is 24 factorial if you wanted to work
them out on a computer you can do it one
of two ways you can do it recursively
and this really as we will see in its
implementation will need a stack oh yes
it will or you can do it iteratively
what does it mean to do it recursively I
will look at it very briefly here but
then I will do this for you on the stack
so here's our recursive definition of
factorial in fact I'm putting a comment
here saying this is the recursive
version what I'm saying here is there
again those of you familiar with any of
the c-like languages you know Java C++
whatever fund is very familiar the
incoming parameter argument is is
sometimes called is labeled n the name
of the function is factorial and the
answer delivered back by factorial will
be an integer answer so every time we
call it it expects an incoming parameter
or argument as it's sometimes called and
it will deliver you back an answer
that's also another integer factorial is
only defined for integers not for real
numbers not for any other sort of thing
only for integers and only for positive
integers it won't even work for negative
ones okay
now this is almost like writing
mathematics it's almost like writing
this definition I had up here look you
say if the incoming argument is 1 then
my answer is 1 the factorial of 1 is 1
so I return to the outside world that
wants to know I return the answer 1
factorial 1 is 1 otherwise I return back
to the outside world that wants to know
I say the factorial of anything else is
n times the factorial of the number 1
less than it
what the secret is here is the factorial
of the next number below you feed in as
the so called actual parameter the thing
that is one less than the N and you've
got at the moment so if we come with
four I return back four times factorial
3 plus n minus 1 if n is 4
that's factorial 300 gosh what this
means is I can't return the answer until
I've worked out what factorial 3 is so I
dive back into this same piece of code
only this time it's still calling it n
but n has now changed into 3 so the
first thing you have to get happy about
is there isn't just one n there's lots
of them they're all calling but they're
all different and they all have to be
managed and kept separate that's the
first thing there is not just one n
recursion wouldn't work if there were
and that way of keeping them separate it
just naturally falls out no prizes for
guessing it's a stack you need a stack
to do this properly here's my main
program here's its environment is its
data what I'm going to do from here the
main program is to say I want factorial
4 in all of its work correctly and have
its own local variables which of course
includes all of these different
instances of n in this case you put on
what's called another stack frame
another whole area of the stack and you
say that one is going to deliver back to
the answer 2 factorial 4 but factorial 4
then says can't work the answer out
until I know what factorial 3 is so
remember this smaller white one is going
to work out factorial 3 it's also does
the usual trick oh I don't know what
factorial 3 is it's 3 times factorial 2
so I've got to know what factorial 2 is
so here is the frame on
stack that will work out factorial -
finally with a great sense of relief
factorial - says all I know is the time
- times factorial 1 there's factorial 1
at last factorial 1 says I know what I
am I am the answer 1 the factorial 2
frame is waiting there on what you might
call a pending multiply it's saying I am
2 times whatever factorial 1 is
factorial 1 says here you go into the
pending multiply the answers 1 and then
the same thing happens Oh so the ask for
factorial 2 is 2 where does that need to
be delivered back - it needs to be
delivered back into the frame below
which is positively gasping because it
wants to do 3 times whatever factorial 2
is it's 3 times 2 now where is it that's
waiting for that 3 times 2 is 6 so
somewhere down here there's a pending
multiply in this frame saying that
factorial 4 is 4 times whatever
factorial 3 was but we just found out
the fact all of three ends up cascading
down delivering 6 4 times 6 is 24 final
pending multiplier was done and it gets
delivered back into the main program and
in the main program that I've got here
we'll put this out of course with a web
link to it all I do with the value when
I get it back is I just print out or so
the answer to factorial 4 is 24 that's
back in the main program area at the
bottom of the stack what you have to
remember is that in these pending
multipliers that we had each one of them
is holding on to a different value of n
as the left hand up around in its
pending multiplier this is saying 4
times something the one above it so 3
times something 2 times something and so
on and the answers cascaded back down
and dropped out at the bottom correctly
we'd like to thank audible.com for
sponsoring this computerphile video
they've got loads of books online so go
on a chat one out go over to audible.com
slash computerphile and you can download
one for free if you sign up there today
I'd like to recommend console wars
brand-new book out by Blake Harris and
it chronicles the console wars of the
90s between Nintendo and Sega and Sega
did something really radical to take on
the massive company it was or
corporation that was Nintendo just shows
how the players change as time goes on
it's a really really interesting story
so check that out remember
audible.com slash computerphile sign up
there to try out a free book thanks once
again to them for supporting this video
and other computerphile videos and right
up at the very top the top of stack is
often called the stack top pointer SP
for short it's not an IBM one it's
developed by a company called Motorola